Voltron has just wrapped up its entire
run with a season finale that will leave
fans debating the events for many years
to come throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the finale as well as the
events that took place in it there will
of course be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to have anything ruined
and I highly suggest that he turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so the big question that is
on everyone's lips is did Allura die
well season 8 finds the paladin's tried
to stop her gar from reverting to her
old persona her Nova in the final battle
Allura the paladins and her Nova are
teleported into a collected
consciousness and plead with her to stop
the destruction they eventually managed
to convince her to restore the universe
but this requires a ritual in which
Allura must sacrifice herself in order
to perform
Allura manages to change the massive
amounts of quintessence her Nova had
collected during the series and
transform it from a destructive life
force into a giving one after a tearful
goodbye
Alura Antonova a walk towards king alfor
la tour and the past paladins including
Zarkon to me this is not a death for the
character but rather a higher plane of
existence in the white lion episode we
learn that there exists a realm outside
of what the main characters exist in and
it's clear that Allura spirit has one
there after a brilliant flash of light
reality is saved and everything seems to
be back to the status quo
except for her Nova and Allura who are
now missing Allura stated that she knew
the risks and it does indeed appear that
she has gone forever from this world the
final scenes of the show display the
universe in a state of unity the planets
have joined the coalition which is now
grown into an even bigger Galactic
Empire of peace the Holts have
established a new generation of
defenders hunc created a food Empire
lands has become a farmer and is living
out a peaceful life spreading the
message of allure air even if he does
miss his former girlfriend
Keith helps with the relief work and
Shiro found love and happiness the show
doesn't end there though and viewers who
stick around right until the end will
see the characters meet to celebrate
that anniversary of Alura sacrifice and
watch as the Voltron lie
at the part the theory that aloha still
lives and now exists on a higher plane
of existence is confirmed here when we
see her as part of the constellations
watching over the galaxy her sacrifice
grunting her life beyond it so what are
your thoughts on the finale of Voltron
do you agree with me and what did you
take from the ending comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's other big
Netflix release bird box which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]